So one thing that we should explain is
the difference between the terminal
and the shell.
>> The terminal is a program
that draws text in a window, and
let's you type things in on a keyboard.
Technically it's called
a terminal emulator,
since it acts like one of those
old school hardware terminals.
It displays output on the screen and
it accepts input from the keyboard.
>> But the terminal itself doesn't
know what to do with that input.
It needs another program to do that.
In this case, that program is the shell.
When you type things in the terminal
just sends what you type to that
separate program.
When you press Enter, the shell
interprets what you wrote as a command,
figures out what program you
want to run, runs it and
sends the output back to the terminal so
you can see it.
>> You could actually use
the terminal without the shell,
with a lot of terminal programs you
can tell it what program to run.
The default is a shell, but
you can have it run say,
the Python interpreter instead.
>> Also, there are actually a lot of
different shell programs that you can
choose from.
The default one on most Linux systems,
and on the Mac, is called GNU Bash.
But there are others called TCSH,
KSH and Seashell.
They all work slightly differently and
have various different features.
For this course,
we're just going to stick with Bash.
>> And you can also use a shell
without the terminal, sort of.
You can write shell commands
into a file and arrange for
your computer to run the shell
program on that file.
This is called shell scripting.
It's a bit of an advanced topic and
we don't go into it in this course.